are going to assist by sitting on a dark
square and we do see young christophe
duda
taking his head yeah it's over young
christophe duda just lost his game
to maximum vaccine so he is down by one
point in the match and he will have to
make a comeback okay and magnus
gesturing as well okay yeah he's not
happy with himself because he's allowed
white queen to sit in front of this
black pawn and now magnus okay he's not
happy because his winning chances have
disappeared that black pawn now it looks
great but it's about to get snapped off
the board by nakamura and once that pawn
disappears so do black's winning chances
now black is actually temporarily a pawn
down but he can win that pawn back and
we're about to see a result nakamura he
saved this one miraculously he's giving
a few checks
really nice defensive play from nakamura
and there we go the black king can't
escape all the checks
it's a draw
all right
i guess that is a good result for minus
it's a decent result but he was
dictating the game he would have taken a
draw beforehand but uh i think nakamura
is the more happy with this result he is
the one who will be relieved after
achieving a very difficult position
after the opening and magnus is actually
sitting there looking over this we
actually rarely see that okay there he
goes
yeah a draw for minus crossing shaking
his head a little bit do you think he's
somewhat unhappy after this game not
clinching the win yeah i think magnus is
never happy even if he plays a
masterpiece he's such a perfectionist he
always wants to play a perfect game a
beautiful game